all right so this is going to be
tutorial as you can see from the top
from the title so after many years i
actually had to have the opportunity to
teach a course on detection estimation
something that is offered in most
electrical engineering courses
electrical engineering departments so
i'm actually writing a book on
informational theory and this is
actually going to be part
of one of the parts of the book uh
the statistical inference part so if you
look in the
you know the typical courses that
you find detection estimation they use
this kind of books
and if you look at the table of contents
you find you know elements of hypothesis
testing the match filter plays a very
important role
um kramer rao and then
a winner and kalman play a very
important role and also
continuous time so um
actually it's very interesting because
uh
there's really no information theory in
any of these
uh in any of these standard courses and
it's interesting because the information
theory community
um was very late in adopting
uh things like for example the relative
entropy
okay so in fact i went to shannon's
archives in the library of congress and
he even keeps the letter that he got
from kulbak
sending him up a paper uh a preprint of
his
paper with the with the coolback library
divergence but he never used it
and other famous information theorists
as gallagher for example never used
relative entropy so it was pretty late
in the game
blayhood and chisar perhaps some of the
russians
realized how important that was
so
interestingly one of the pioneers in
in detection estimation was shannon
himself
in fact in 1944 he didn't publish this
this was just
a technical memorandum in the labs
he actually came up with the derivation
of
the optimality of the match filter but
unlike
what north and middle and middleton had
done
right about that time in which they just
showed that the match filter was the
solution of a maximal signal to noise
ratio problem
he actually showed that it was the
solution to a minimum probability of
federal problem
not only that he did it in uh in um
in the colored noise so this is really
the beginning of communication theory is
this technical memorandum here
all right so this is the structure of
the course information measures
sufficient statistics binary hypothesis
testing emory hypothesis testing which
is very important
for us and then estimation so what you
need to know about information measures
so this is just the notation and then
you're going to see this
uh quite a bit in the talk the logarithm
of the uh uh
rather nicotine derivative between p and
q i'm going to denote as
this that's what we call the relative
information
and of course the expectation of that
with respect to p
is the relative entropy but very
important for what i'm
what i'm doing well now it's not just
the expectation of that random variable
but
its distribution okay so the cdf of the
relative information sometimes we call
that
the relative information spectrum
okay in the special case where uh you
have a conditional distribution an
unconditional distribution then we call
that the information density
of course the expectation is the mutual
information
all right so um
you know the first person to to deal
with big data was fisher and he was
interested from going
from big data to uh to not so big data
so he came up with the concept of
sufficient statistic
and when he described it he has the word
information there
so um you know there must be some
relationship
with information theory and in fact if
you look at covering thomas in his first
in their first chapter you already find
a section on sufficient statistics
and they define it as
as a function of the data such that the
mutual information
is preserved after you take that
function
mutual information from the unknown
parameter
to the observables is the same as from
the unknown parameter to
the statistic now of course this
the parameter when you define sufficient
statistics need not have
a distribution so this is actually true
for all possible distributions
on uh theta okay so it's kind of like
saying well all by
all basian forms of the problem will
satisfy
that property oops i don't know what
they did now
okay so this is something that in fact
you see
throughout the statistical inference
literature
and also signal processing and this
drives me crazy
the the observations they denote as x
and that's not
something you know that's something you
you should never do
so the obser so the observations are why
okay this is the yucky stuff with noise
and then uh this is the statistic the
thing that then
you go from big data to small data all
right
x-cam versus the y-cam
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we are we're
waiting
all right so the the official definition
is that
uh when you know there is any residual
randomness in this c
uh is not going to i mean any residual
randomness in y
one once you know z is not going to be
due to the unknown parameter
all right but information theoretically
you can either do it
like covering thomas or in fact you can
show
that you have this
property that in fact the information
density that i defined before
is preserved from v to y and from v to c
and this is non-basis and you don't need
you don't need a distribution on v to be
able to define this all you need is
really
a reference measure for why this is an
auxiliary reference measure that
dominates the whole class
of possible uh models if there is not
no such thing that dominates everything
then then you are
you are in bad shape so this is actually
much uh
nicer than the usual factorization
theorem
which is only uh it's only true it's
only
uh applicable to deterministic
sufficient statistics
but in fact in practice you may actually
have situations where you have
random statistics so for example you may
have a sampler
and that sampler may have an offset but
yet
if you sample at the nyquist rate you're
going to have sufficiency
all right so in the case of a binary
parameter
so the model only consists of the two
distributions then this boils down
to the information density excuse me
the relative information with the data
being the same as the relative
information
with the statistic and then
if if the
the relative entropy or at the
statistics is finite
then you might as well this easier
use this easier condition where
the the data processing is satisfied
with equality
but if it's not finite the fact that
this is infinite equals infinite then
that that does not uh imply that you
have sufficient statistics so this is
more general
all right so now let's go to hypothesis
testing
binary hypothesis testing uh
traditionally this is the kind of
terminology that is used
null hypothesis alternative hypothesis
you have a hunch
and then if your your experiment
validates your hunch then you can go
ahead and publish it
and that's if so h1 is true
you call that the alternative hypothesis
and then you have all these kind of
names for
for going from one hypothesis to the
other depending on the
um on the um
on the application so i don't like i
don't like to use any of that
terminology because for us
in uh in communications h0 and h1
are on equal footing okay usually it's
like a bit
you know it's either zero or one so
there is no
no alternative and no uh no null they
are both
equal so the only thing we have to
remember is pi
zero given one probability of deciding
zero
given the h1 is true and vice versa so i
don't use that terminology and in fact
i'm tempted
not to use the terminology of hypothesis
testing maybe decisions should be better
but i chickened out and i uh i in fact
um continue using hypothesis testing not
to be too
contrarian all right so here uh
the the fundamental tradeoff then is the
region that you can achieve
between the two error probabilities
and and that's the lower envelope
so that's where the action is now
you know of course all the uh asymptotic
results the large deviation result
churn of stein lemma and when both
probabilities go to zero exponentially
and so on we do
do that in the club in the class but as
always
what i do is present the results in the
in what i call the single shot mode
so we're always assuming that we have
just one quantity
that is not necessarily
multi-dimensional that's not necessarily
have an infinite an inf uh um
dimensionality it goes to infinity
then we get bounds upper and lower
bounds on that
and then once we have that then it's
pretty easy then to get
the asymptotics so what i'm going to
show you here is a selection of the
bounds
of the achievability and converse bounds
okay so first of all let me just
uh say that by going to the bayesian
case then you have a very nice
a kind of operational characterization
for this
relative information is the added
the the added evidence in favor of one
hypothesis
versus the other ones you see the
observations
all right so then this uh is actually
this bound
is is implicit in a paper by walt in
1945
even though he was using relative
entropy he didn't know he was using
relative entropy
but that actually predates uh
coolbuckling library
and that's just the the data processing
inequality so that's
that's a pretty powerful um
a achievability result excuse me a
converse result
another converse result you can get just
simply by
change of measure and notice that now we
already have
the distribution of the relative
information now this one is something
that you haven't seen and it's a cute
result
that um i got by distilling kind of like
the key idea
in shannon gallagher in berlin camp
which is a very very famous paper
in information theory uh it's actually
the last paper that shannon wrote
or the channel was a co-author of
all right so then the only thing i need
to tell you here is
that uh what p alpha is all right so we
have
p0 and p1 and then p alpha is the tilted
version
so it's the one that you get
by taking a convex combination
of the relative informations and then
you normalize it so that
it's a distribution okay and the
normalization that involves
the rainy divergence
okay so this of course is instrumental
this converse is instrumental later when
you go to the
asymptotic asymptotic paradigm
to uh as we will see later to give you
the
the the actual uh result
that tells you how fast you can have
both uh error probabilities goes to c
go to zero exponentially fast now as far
as achievability
the interesting thing is that uh
in contrast to most problem in in
shannon theory
in this one we have actually
a constructive method that actually we
know what the optimal rule because
that's a name and person
name and person rule okay so that's a
luxury that we have
and that certainly makes the analysis
a lot easier this one is very simple
again
involves some change of very simple
change of measure
argument now this one what happens here
is then the achievability result again
here the non-asymptotic achievability
result
is very simple you just have a
deterministic threshold test
and and a change of measure and then
using that converse that i showed you
before
that i said was distilled from shannon
gallagher in burlingame that's when you
can show
that these things are asymptotically
tight once you take the logarithm
and you normalize by one over n
all right so now emery hypothesis
testing so
for us this is fundamental right because
this is
all uh all about decoding
you have an error control system you
have to decide
between one among several messages
and so this is actually for us
completely fundamental
in digital communications statisticians
you don't see a lot you know you take a
book on a hypothesis testing you're not
going to see a lot of memory hypothesis
testing
the one case where they are really uh
interested in doing that is in
non-parametric
estimation where there is this trick to
get a lower bound we have a space
of possible parameters
and i think this is due to ibrahimo ibra
ibrahim ibrahimovic
hasminsky so the idea here is that you
have a genie
that tells you well actually
i'll tell you that the true one is
belongs to a finite class and then if
this finite class
you know you you have a minimum distance
between the errors
the distortions of this minimum class
then you can lower bound
the uh average distortion by
the minimum distance times the
probability of error for a emery
hypothesis testing problem
so that's why then in statistics some of
our
beloved converse bounds like thanos
inequality
have been used and binu has written a
paper on
nice paper and several methods that are
popular
in that respect all right so what about
achievability what kind of bounds can we
find for achievability
here and i'm only going to use i'm gonna
only gonna uh
show you the bayesian case because we
don't have much time
so as you can see every every time i've
shown you a bound so
far the bound either had relative
entropy
or relative information now we have
conditional
entropy uh so this
remember this is the error probability
now bayesian error probability so we
have a distribution
on v and um
you know that result is is a is a
kind of like an old result and the way
you prove this
is by first considering the blind case
so
where you don't have any observations so
then you have
you have that and then and then you
condition on
on one observation and then you take the
average so this
is actually a special case of this other
theorem
this is not new even though the form in
which i express it here
is new and this is actually goes back to
the
1960s a paper by tabe and dwyer
uh now this one is uh
is quite easy to prove and in fact what
you need to do in order to prove this
result
is exactly what you need to do in order
to prove shannon's achievability
uh a result
for for channel coding where essentially
you say well
uh let me look at the uh at the
likelihood
once i have the observation and let me
put a threshold rather than
having an optimum rule that selects the
maximum you put a threshold if there is
no one above threshold or more than one
then you say okay i give up
all right so the only thing between the
only difference between this result
and shannon's theorem is that here you
don't need to use random coding
okay because the the optimal decision
rule
is known so that's that's a pretty
powerful
the only thing here i didn't define
maybe i should have defined in the
beginning
this is the information function okay so
this has the logarithm
of the reciprocal of the probability
all right so now let's go to converses
all right so the converse says
uh of course the first one is finals
inequality
and here we just turn it around usually
we
um we upper bound the conditional
entropy now we have it
and the other way around now shannon for
some reason never liked to use
fanuc inequality he came up with his own
inequality
uh and which is harder to prove and
essentially for the purposes of uh
asymptotic theorems and so on is as
powerful as fano
now here uh we came up with this
converse
for uh minimum error probability and in
fact this
this beats the other converse i showed
you uh
most of the time and in fact generalizes
these converse i had with han
and notice that the beauty of this is
that it's kind of like a duel of the
achievability result because the
achievability result had here
less than or equal an infimum and then
hit plus
and n plus here okay wow
so um
so you know that's uh that's nice and
then
in fact this is all all these things are
special cases
of uh the metaconverse that jury uh
polyansky um had in his thesis
and in fact this metaconverse what you
do here is you introduce a
an auxiliary distribution and
and then depending on how clever you are
in finding that
auxiliary distribution then you can get
pretty tight results and in fact it has
been shown recently
that by being very clever then you can
find actually
equality in that in that meta converse
the only problem with this
it sounds like sounds like nirvana
because here you have equality so you
don't really need to worry about bounce
anymore
the only problem is that the auxiliary
distribution
in fact when you compute it the
normalizing constant
is as hard to compute as this
okay that as far as i mean um
conceptually it's nice to know that the
metaconverse can be tied
all right so i think uh i don't have a
lot of time left
but as far as estimation uh
i i put most of the emphasis on bayesian
estimation but
i do like to uh um
show like for example the kramer
outbound which is called the information
inequality sometimes
um it's actually cleaner to do it in
this way
uh hammers the chap and robins where in
fact
this has a very simple proof this is
completely
um completely general and this is in the
case of unbiased and this guy here
is the person divergence
okay so that's a special case of an f
divergence
and then you can recover this is
stronger than grammar raw you can
recover kramer rao
and the way i like to define fischer's
information
is not the standard way but the way i
like to do it
is by taking the derivative of
the um of the relative entropy of course
coolback and liblar already already
noticed that you had
that property in the paper where they
introduce
the relative entropy okay but it's much
nicer
to give the definition in this way which
is much more
um kind of intuitive and then show the
standard
thing with the partial derivatives and
so on as
um as a result
okay and then in patient estimation um
in basian estimation uh the mmsc
then then i showed the uh
the the bayesian climate rail bound or
the bantry's inequality
and then of course these guys are are
the conditional
um fishers information and the
unconditional one this is the original
one
due to fissure which just shows you if
you
get a carbon copy of your density and
you move it a little bit
how different it is from the original
one so that you can put as a special
case
of the general one now
particular interest interesting here is
the case
where the observations are contaminated
by additive
gaussian noise and in that case the mmsc
as a function of the distribution of the
unknown quantity
and the signal to noise ratio so we use
that notation mmc
x alpha and that of course has turned
out to have very important
connections with uh with information
theory
that we discovered a few years ago
but before i showed you that since it's
electrical engineering course then it's
nice to show some
uh circuits so that's the most
elementary
uh cir estimator that you can find in
the world
then if you have rather than random
variables you have stationary processes
then these resistors now become transfer
functions and then you have the
non-causal winner filter i don't do
causal wiener filtering which is a waste
of time
and i do i do do
the kalman filter
but just because i have to um
and then uh and then you see then then
there are all these but
uh marcelo is uh doesn't want me to
continue so
i'll just i'll just show you the main
thing and the main
thing the main surprising thing is that
in fact if you integrate this guy
this mmc over all signal-to-noise ratios
if you have never seen this this is
really cool then you get the entropy
okay so you have the the world of uh
of wiener and all these people gauss and
so on in the world of shannon
on that side okay so that's a special
case of this
of that formula all right so um
so i know that many of you came because
of
of this uh
so this actually this picture i'm here
uh
eating uh eating jamon
iberico which is one of the most
delectable things
in life although some people because of
religious superstitions
refuse to take it
all right so how do you look uh
in minnesota and red platform boots so
so there there i am okay this is me
okay
16 years old and
yeah so in fact my legs are pretty much
the same
okay thank you
so questions why did we get ready for
the next speaker
sergio yeah so this workshop and i'm
glad to see that you're doing this
hypothesis thing again and this is a
workshop on big data and i've been
reading some papers they all look at
precision and recall
you want to say something about it i
have no idea i mean i
recall
look at any date i mean they do
inference big data papers they all talk
about pr
precision recall
that shows you how little life right of
that literature because
it's a completely different world
altogether and um
so what's what's the punch line i'm
asking whether you would want to
include what precision recall means in
this language
i don't i don't even know i mean i don't
recall there was some recall in
california for the governor